some conservative politicians I'm
thinking of trump
I'm thinking of Victor Orban in Hungary
I'm thinking of Georgia Maloney in Italy
you know I love her
they're the kinds of politicians who run
and they don't just say the same old
platitudes they say no this is rigged I
know it's rigged I've seen it be rigged
Trump famously would say I know the
system is totally corrupt because I've
used it to my advantage
yeah I used to donate to Democrats
because I greased the wheels and I'd buy
them off you're right that's what
happens in this in this uh form of
government so Georgia Maloney just did
this Georgia Maloney just put the rest
of the EU specifically France on blast
on their ridiculous Arguments for why
they've got to flood Europe with
foreigners here's her argument I'll
Translate
these countries and it allows them to
take the exports
this is a child she's holding on a
picture this is a child who works in a
gold mine in Burkina Faso it's one of
the poorest countries
the goal that this child goes down
mostly ends up in the French State
the solution here is not to take
Africans and bring them to Europe
the solution is to liberate Africa from
the Europeans who are exploiting it and
allow these people to keep what they
have and live on what they have
beautiful beautiful stuff you can see
here not only a a good political end in
sight which is to stop the mass
migration to Europe which the European
people rightly don't like because it's
it's Lawless and it's unsustainable and
it will deprive them of their own
culture if you if you just flood a
country with new people and you don't
assimilate those people in any way which
is not it's not even possible the amount
of time that these people are coming in
then then you you destroy your own
culture and and so the way she's doing
it though
is she's making an argument that will be
that will be appealing to a broad array
of people she's not saying those awful
Africans we hate those Africans don't
let those Africans come in she's saying
the arguments that France is making are
Preposterous France is making the
argument that we need to take in all
these Africans and by the way the
Africans are mostly going to places like
Italy they're going to these first ports
of lampedusa and these kind of places
where they first come to and she says
but
that you're making the argument that we
need to take these people in because
their countries are so poor but you
France you're looting those countries
you're exploiting those people and you
are profiting yourself and then you want
other people to pick up the tab and
that's so often what happens that's what
happens here with our woke corporations
our woke corporations will
will flood the country with illegal
aliens they will encourage it's not just
the Democrats encouraging illegal
immigration it's these corporations it's
it's the Chamber of Commerce too because
they know that it will give them cheap
labor
it'll reduce the costs of Labor and then
all the externalities all of the costs
that go along cultural
political Financial costs that go along
with illegal immigration crime
these companies say okay everyone else
has to deal with it it is just it it
really ends up being pretty simple
it is a consequence of turning politics
away from the common good of the whole
nation to provide for the general
welfare to think of us as a community as
a United States of America
toward an entirely selfish view of
politics which we obviously see on the
left the left's new moral Maxim knew
it's been their moral Maxim now for 60
70 years is if it feels good do it if I
want to do it then I'm going to do it
you do you fine but but people on the
right have done this too this is the
rights adoption of greed is good there's
no such thing as the common good the
virtue of selfishness nonsense well it's
the left and the right both doing that
and what's the effect of it to rob the
country of of any sense of the common
good of any sense of commonality of any
sense that we're a country at all right
now head on over to establishtitles.com
Knowles established titles is your
opportunity to earn the title of Lord or
lady and gain the respect you deserve
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land in Scotland okay I had this
problem where I thought I'm just not
getting the respect that is due to me
okay people when they come up to me they
say hey Michael
hey Mr note mister
I want to be referred to as a lard or a
lord okay there is this uh wonderful
Scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lards and ladies well in
your title pack you will be bestowed
with at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston Scotland plus an official
certificate with a Crest your
certificate features a unique plot
Number with which you can see the exact
location of your land title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion there are a couple
packs because you don't want to let your
wife you know just be some strumpet
you're a Lord and then she's just some
chick on the street so you want her to
be a lady as well established titles
told me that the first 200 people to
purchase a title pack using my exclusive
link will receive a plot within walking
distance of mine depending on how many
of you want to become a lord or a lady
we can begin to build our own kingdom
established titles is actually running a
massive sale right now and if you use
code Knowles at checkout you will get an
additional 10 off go to
establisheditles.com Knowles to get your
gifts now and help support the channel
Adam kinzinger you know the male
allegedly male Liz Cheney comes out he
goes on MSNBC and he whines and he
whines he says this isn't the GOP this
isn't this is tribalism it's all the
same rhetoric from seven years ago
why do you think more people don't feel
that he crossed their red lines in the
Republican party right you know part of
its tribalism right you know the second
if if one of them says look I've had
enough with Donald Trump you get kicked
out of your tribe look when I got
elected I remember I just gotten out of
Iraq this was 2009 I got elected in
2010. and I remember thinking if I'm
gonna ask people to be willing to die
for this country and obviously I'm gonna
have to take votes on that and I have I
have to be willing to give up my career
for the same cause now that sounds
Innovative but it's so true you know we
we swear an oath to the Constitution not
because what we're going to do is easy
and not because I have to take a poll
every time I vote on things like should
Donald Trump be impeached and what does
my district say it's because my oath is
not to my district
it's to the Constitution
and there he is Valiant Adam kinzinger
giving up his seat for the cause of our
democracy
and to fight that evil tribalism first
of all Adam kinzinger did not sacrifice
his seed for anything Noble his his
district was erased because of
redistricting in the state of Illinois
okay now maybe had Adam kinsinger
played his cards a little bit smarter
and had a little bit more backbone
politically uh maybe he would have been
able to remain uh
viable in politics but he didn't and his
his district was erased and now he's
pretending to be a martyr when in fact
he's not but it's that first part that
really gets me is there any stupider
word in our current political discourse
than tribalism
yes there is the one the one stupider
word is authoritarianism because it
doesn't mean anything because every both
sides accuse one another of being
authoritarian and by that they mean
seeking to impose any Vision on politics
which is just what politics is that's
just what self-government is doesn't
mean anything you you think we should
live according to the laws that you and
your community believe in how
authoritarian is just what
that's just called politics man that's
just called self-government so that
might be the one word that's slightly
Dumber but the the second dumbest word
is tribalism it's all this tribalism
what do you think politics is
do you think politics
this actually is probably why these
people have a very skewed political view
politics is a team sport in order to do
anything in politics you have to have
allies and you have to have shared goals
and you have to have a division of labor
and you have to have a strategy and you
go and you work together and you get
something done that's politics politics
means public
it doesn't mean personal it doesn't mean
you just do whatever you want
individually all the time
it is tribal and why are there political
tribes
well largely because people have a
shared view of the world and if you
believe that human life has value
then you're going to oppose abortion
and you're also going to oppose
transiting the kids they don't seem like
they're totally related but they share
basic premises about what human life is
who we are where we come from there are
many more examples of that very often
the political tribes that we are so
quick to decry these days
coherent tribes it makes sense
it makes sense that the Democrats who
have no respect for our Traditions are
happy to Outsource our jobs
destroy our communities
obliterate the family open up our
borders it's in throw away our
sovereignty give it to International
institutions
and make sense
frankly we need more tribalism we need
we need clearer tribalism at least on
the right because you've got good
tribalism on the left
or good I mean you've got effective
tribalism on the left that's why the
left is much more effective at wielding
political power the right needs to do
that a little bit better we're not going
to do it with these you know parading
drama queens like Adam kinzinger who who
do nothing but adore themselves on MSNBC
all the time now today's music Monday
and I am told by my producers that were
listening to rap music today
great
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]